i'm jane secker
and this is episode nine of storycast
21.
in 2007 a shooting in the uk midlands
sparked a war between
two biker gangs so serious the 13 years
on
members of both gangs refused to speak
about it
but in this installment of storycast 21
one former gang member
has agreed to speak with us thereby
giving us access to this story
because of fears for his safety we're
using an actor
to voice his testimony this is the uk
biker wars
my name is darren little and on sunday
august 12 2007 i had a phone call from
the sky news desk
saying that there'd been a shooting on
the m40 motorway
near warwick i got there as quickly as i
could
it was a lovely summer's day lots of
people out of their cars all over the
motorway it was a very strange scene
and all of us knew that the bulldog bash
had been going on that weekend
a massive massive event and this was
attended by
hell's angels from all over the world
and there was some kind of a score
settling or a feud that had gone on
seven members of the outlaws murdered
house angel jerry
tobin on the m40 we learned that the
biker who was shot was called jerry
tobin
he was 35 years old a house angel and a
mechanic
from south london and the police very
very quickly arrested
a number of members of the outlaws a
motorcycle group
which was the sworn enemy of the hell's
angels
and there seemed little doubt among
outlaw bikers
just why jerry tobin was shot
jerry tobin got shot because the hell's
angels had taken over a smaller club's
rally
the bulldog bash in the midlands in
outlaw country
i think after a few meetings a few cross
words
they decided we'd have to do something
about this and that
would have come from america they would
have said you've got to do something
about this
[Music]
this was a murder which was audacious
really
these members of the outlaws had spent a
number of
days planning this hit
it's thought that they were traveling at
90 miles an hour at the time
jerry tobin was in the middle lane of
the motorway
and the car with the outlaws in was in
the outside lane
and they wound the windows down and the
two shots were fired
he was shot because he was wearing a
patch they didn't sing them out by name
but you live that life and sooner or
later something like that is going to
happen
what started with a phone call for me to
go and cover a story on a
quiet sunday afternoon you know would
lead me into a world that i had no
idea of
there were a number of people both from
the bike of fraternity
itself and also within law enforcement
who
started to tip me off
a lot of that violence comes down the
chain
you might see reprisal happen to you for
something that happened in another
country
it's really personal one of them was a
biker that will call for the sake of
this
ed just to protect his identity he was a
one percenter
biker and he was someone who knew an
awful lot
about the biker groups
the outlaws only exist in this country
because of the hell's angels
the hells angels were bullying a lot of
clubs in the midlands
so the clubs got together called
themselves the midland outlaws
and eventually got sanctioned by the
american outlaws
there's the the old story that back in
the 60s when you had the war veterans
coming home
it was a big party in a town in
california
which uh which descended into drunken
anarchy and the american motorcycle
association said
99 of our members are law-abiding
citizens who ride and race motorcycles
so of course these people who want no
part of that mainstream
motorcycle culture call themselves the
one percenters
i suppose there isn't an expectation of
criminality because
i know i know loads of guys are as
straight as anything
but there's an expectation of being a
being a bad boy the hell's angels view
it as a sort of gangster
badge of pride as i dug deeper
i found out that actually violence
between the house angels and
various biker groups around the world
had been going on for quite some time
so far the major flashpoints have been
in europe australia and canada
with tit-for-tat murders beatings
[Music]
and bombings of rival clubhouses
in june 2007 a rival biker gang were
responsible for detonating a bomb
outside a clubhouse of the hells angels
in a sydney suburb and in canada
in quebec there was a huge rivalry going
on
throughout the late 90s and into the
early 2000s between the hells angels
and various other biker gangs that left
more than 160 people dead
the outlaws are at war with the hell's
angels the outlaws have
murdered a member of the hell's angels
and previously the hell's angels
have killed members of the oakland just
because they're rival gangs
it's about camaraderie brotherhood
like-minded people nowadays it's
it's mainly 50 50 with ex-servicemen and
people who've never served
it's not a deal breaker you're the right
sort of person your job or your
background doesn't matter
as long as you can be where you need to
be answer the phone and
live by that time schedule if law
enforcement does tolerate
something like the murder of jerry told
them if you do that you run the risk
of doing the same as happened in
australia as
happened in other parts of the world
where this has been allowed to continue
and escalate
as the investigation went deeper into
what had happened surrounding jerry
tobin
the authorities began to label
all of the biker gangs but particularly
the hells angels and the outlaws a
serious organized crime group
and then we find out that the most
powerful outlaw outside of north america
is based out of north wales out of
colwin bay
and is a man called dink according to
the police this man is the head of one
of europe's fastest growing organized
crime groups
i was just fascinated to find out about
him find out about
the structure of the outlaws
so within six months of jerry tobin
being shot
on the m40 the outlaws and the hell's
angels were at it again in the mid lanes
this time at birmingham airport then
around
30 outlaws and hell's angels took part
in a mass brawl
members of both groups had found
themselves on the same flight back into
birmingham from alicante
they both made calls to their people on
the ground in the midlands to tell them
to meet them when they landed at the
airport
some had hammers knives even a meat
cleaver
in total 30 bikers assembled in the
arrivals hall at birmingham airport and
started attacking each other
now miraculously no one was killed west
midlands police recently spent a
reported 2 million pounds
on security for a trial of angels and
outlaws
after this took place amid massive
security cost more than 2 million pounds
for the police
but ultimately four house angels and
four outlaws
were arrested and subsequently found
guilty and this was happening
in the early summer of 2009
but around about the time when the
airport trial ended
i came across a number that i was told
could be for dink
it was so tantalizing to get his number
and to think that
i had a chance of getting in touch with
someone who'd never spoken
particularly for someone who was
becoming ever more the focus of the
police's attention
he's known as dink and is the european
and asian president
of the outlaws motorcycle club a group
which is growing quickly when i finally
rang him
i think he swore and he asked me how i
got the number
and i i said well you know i just came
by it
this was july 2009 two years after tobin
and it's just over a year after the
birmingham airport riot
and i said to him we always hear from
the house angels and we never hear from
you guys
and i want to give you that opportunity
to to tell us about what you say because
the police are saying an awful lot of
things about your organization
the hell's angels clearly are always
talking to the media
and we never hear from you guys and i i
want to hear what you've got to say i
want to hear your side of the story
and he said okay fine yeah
let's do it a few words for level okay
give us your name first of all
he said that we would meet up at the
rock and blues festival in derbyshire
which is their version of the bulldog
bash
warwickshire police claim the outlaws
and the house angels
are in a bitter and increasingly violent
feud so we hatched a plan
basically that i would text my line
manager
every half an hour both are involved in
drugs prostitution
murder extortion and we had certain
code words that i would text if we were
okay
and code words that i would text if
there was a problem
all rock radio yeah say what should we
start that again
yeah well this is just so they showed us
in and they took us to a huge marquee
and there was a bar inside there was
music playing and the place was
full of outlaws this show this year gone
really well
and i was very nervous i won't lie to
you because
now we were kind of in the heart of
their enormous
festival you have had licensing
and after about half an hour dink walked
in
presumably you'd prefer to be known as
dave yeah yeah he had his
outlaws jacket on um he was bare chested
underneath
tattoos all over him relatively short
and stocky
and he came over and and shook my hand
sorry yeah it was a case of how far can
i go i'm on your territory
here i'm aware that if i upset you
that we could have a problem so what are
your feelings towards the house angels
my feelings is just let them get on with
what they're doing and we'll get on with
that what we're doing you know
is there a feud yeah but they see
events like happen with jerry tobin on
the m40
these things happen i don't know you
know
that was duly punished for it everybody
knows that because it was on every
newspaper you know
did you know about that well obviously i
went to the court case
prior to it happening no no what was
your feeling when you found out about it
then
well my feeling was
it's a rather stupid thing to do it just
gives
all the authorities and everything the
ammunition they've just been looking
for you know what can i say
what's your attitude to them now you
know i mean fundamentally in that
conversation
dink denied that he knew anything about
the shooting of tobin and actually said
he thought it was a
stupid thing to do at the time because
it brought the police's attention
onto the outlaws because i mean they say
murder prostitution extortion
firearms drugs what they've done that or
us
[Music]
if any of our lads have done anything
wrong we've been punished for it
you know but any walks of life what any
you know
any professional or any club sporters or
organizations you can always get a few
people who do things wrong
what if they get punished to get
punished what can i say you know
he denied that they were an organized
crime group you made a joke about them
being
disorganized um and so he was
he played a very straight bat do you
know any house angels are you friends
with any house angels
there's too many i don't know too many
outlaws you know so by the time i've
gone around all of them you know i ain't
got time for other
things but and i'll dislike oh my god i
just don't think about it
it's just whatever they do he's entirely
up to them and i wish him well
but i mean it does seem to be a
catalogue of events of tit for tat you
know we've had birmingham airport we had
tobin
we've had any number in europe
what can i say you know these things up
i mean do you defend yourselves but
actually at the time we spoke
the police were already looking at dink
and
they had started to look at the north
wales chapter
of the outdoors and their supply of
drugs
are you worried at the police attitude
because clearly they seem to be
tightening up they seem to have their
focus on yourselves and the house angels
[Music]
i suppose if they're picking on us to
leave you to someone else alone
you know what i mean we
did the interview and we put it out on
the first day of the bulldog bash
which annoyed the hell's angels and then
i got a call
the following year early the following
year saying that there was
a case that the police were taking
against dink
and six other outlaws to do with
drugs offenses and that led me back to
dink
in may 2010 to
a small court in carnarvon in north
wales
and at that point i think he knew that
there was an inevitability about what
had happened and he was
frustrated and ultimately dink was
jailed for five years
seven members of the outlaws murdered
house angel jerry tobin
on the m40 in 2007 a crime that
ultimately
drew the police's attention to the
motorbike gangs
and he actually spoke to me quite early
on about the fact that our interview had
led the police to him
and i respectfully reminded him
actually as he said in his interview
with me
the year earlier that the thing that
really led the police to the outlaws and
ultimately to this conviction that he
got for the drug offense
was the shooting of jerry tobin on the
m40 the men were sentenced to life in
prison
all of them are still supported by the
outlaws
in 2021 the surviving members of the
outlaws who carried out jerry tobin's
murder
remain in prison one of them
died in custody in 2019.
dink whose real name is stuart dawson
he's now free again
and remains the most powerful outlaw
outside of north america
[Music]
violence among many uk biker gangs
continues to simmer
dink and the angels claim there is no
feud
but both are well aware that whatever
the truth
[Music]
the uk bike awards was written and
produced by rob mulhern
next time we mark the 10th anniversary
of amy winehouse's death
with a unique insight into the singer's
life
she used to always say to me when i was
like 9 10. i'm gonna sign you one day
didn't even know what that meant i was
just like okay sure
and slowly it just kind of became kind
of like a
a guardian angel really in a music way
with amy